so on the ninth day of Christmas is
something special to me because it was a
present from my daughter she gave it to
me
that my grandson's birthday party
because our birthdays are very close
together and it's a periodic table
handkerchief not a very big handkerchief
but big enough to be useful
unfortunately it doesn't have some of
the later elements but you could argue
if you're going to blow your nose on it
perhaps it's just as well that it's not
too up-to-date but I think it is quite
fun and it's very clear compared to some
of the other periodic tables that you
get and it's really good because you can
hear from my voice I've got a cold
so here goes oh very much so I always
have two one in each pocket otherwise I
sneeze in the most embarrassing way I've
always had handkerchiefs since I was a
child and I used to wipe up the
chemicals with my handkerchief and when
I was at school one day in the chapel in
the prayers I pulled my handkerchief out
of the pocket and it just turned to
powder because the chemicals had all
rotted it away so nowadays I don't mop
up my chemicals with my handkerchief on
day 9 we have periodic table thanks to a
charred piece of wood
day 7 a fan from a fan Carbon anthracite
a glowing plectrum for drinking
receptacles to hear
table bed covers and one piece of
tartaric acid from a Swiss wine barrel
what will be dating